- Hi, I'm Hannah, you're
friendly neighborhood Wine Mom.
In light of everything that has happened
I want to talk about
The Worst Thing's About Being a Woman.
First, when you get home
at the end of the day
and you see that you've been
going around the entire day
with lipstick all over your teeth.
I talked to a good three
people throughout the day
who I thought were my friends
and they failed to tell
me and just made me
go on looking like a
doofus the entire day.
Next, when you go to put up
your hair and you realize
you have no hair tie.
Bonus point if it's a windy day.
Double bonus if you're wearing lip gloss.
I'm Hair Mouth.
Next, the wage gap.
Next, periods.
They suck, everybody knows this.
This is like the most commonly known fact
but I just have to bring
light to it because
oh my God, why does your punish
you for not being pregnant?
It should be a reward.
Next, underwear.
I don't know who formulates
the patterns for underwear
but like thongs suck.
Who finds comfort in pulling
something up their butt?
But if I wear something that's
a little more comfortable
and loose and has more coverage,
all of the sudden it's
called Granny Panty.
You can never win.
Next, when you have a
chain necklace and it gets a knot.
I've spent like 45 minutes
trying to get a knot out.
You have to like mush them
around until they get loose
and then try to take the apart.
It's almost like surgery.
I pay my little sister
who has tinier fingers
to do it for me.
Next, straight white men
wanting to control your uterus.
Next, when your period comes
it's always at a very inconvenient time.
I'll be like waiting
and waiting and waiting
like 'Come on, Period,
I know you're coming'
and it's not until I'm in the
middle of a big presentation
in front of a room full of people
and I'm like 'Now look at this-
ah, fuck'.
Next, taking a tampon to the bathroom.
I don't know who designed the
packaging of these tampons
but it's like fucking Christmas morning
anytime you're trying to take
a tampon out of your purse.
(paper crinkling sound)
Next, we're not able to stand up and pee.
We went camping last
weekend and it was dark
and the bathrooms were disgusting
and it was cold and I had to
pee squatting in the bushes
and I don't know if I'm doing it wrong
but the pee gets all over you.
Next, having to pay for birth control.
Next, childbirth.
We did a whole video on that, go watch it.
Next, walking alone at night.
I walk with my keys between my fingers.
My mom has sent me an
alarm to attach to my keys
in case I'm in trouble.
That's how concerned she is for me
walking alone in the dark.
That's a sad reality of our society
is that women do not
feel safe doing something
as simple as walking down the street.
Last, dresses with no pockets.
So that's all I've got for today.
I'm Hannah, your friendly
neighborhood Wine Mom.
If there's anything I missed in this video
leave it in the comments and as always
if there's anything you
want me to talk about
in a future episode leave
that in the comments as well.
And I know I talked about the
worst parts of being a woman
but the best part about being a woman
is all of you guys who watch this series.
I love all the women who watch this
and all the men
and I love you guys and
together we're strong
and together we're amazing.
Until next time.
(jazzy saxophone playing)